à la différence de mes camarades passé
j'ai moins d'expertisé en des sujets
autres que les notes de musique mais on
m'a convié à venir discuter avec vous et
pour raconter un peu mon quotidien que
certains trouvent atypique mais qui moi
me plaît beaucoup
j'ai commencé la guitare quand j'étais
tout petit avec mon père lui même
musicien quand j'avais 5 ans il m'a
tendu cette cette guitare enfin une
autre un peu plus petit mais c'est
lietaer classique et et j'ai étudié avec
beaucoup de passion la musique classique
à bordeaux ma ville de départ fille
j'éprouve suivi mes études au
conservatoire supérieur de paris et en
marge de cette formation j'ai passé
aussi beaucoup de concours
internationaux des compétitions de
musique un voyage pas très heureux
musique et compétition ne fonctionne pas
l'apparence mais il se trouve que c'est
un tremplin et un peu inévitable dans la
vie d'un musicien classique qui veut
faire carrière
donc j'ai été pris de passion pour cet
univers et j'ai passé beaucoup de
concours dans les grandes villes du
monde
un peu comme des compétitions de tennis
où on se rencontrait tous un peu
l'élite de notre discipline de jacques
pays et mon jeune âge et ma naïveté m'a
permis d'appréhender tout ça avec avec
un côté un peu comme de jouer jouer aux
échecs et ses petites choses moi j'ai la
chance de gagner 13 premiers prier et de
nombreux autres et c'était une forme de
petit record un site assez ses succès
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir de nouveaux
concerts de nombreux concerts un peu le
but de tout cela et depuis j'ai 32 ans
aujourd'hui est donc depuis bientôt
douze voire 14 ans je vis en voyages
incessants je viens un nomade
je vais de salles de concerts en salle
de concert je n'ai pas de maison et je
vis dans les hôtels deux jours par ci
deux jours par là guidé par un parent ma
guitare je vais jouer quelques notes
enfin un petit intermède et je
poursuivrai si vous le voulez bien
voici donc une musique dance show cubain
qui s'appelle leo brouwer qui raconte le
temps qui passe ça s'appelle un mondial
de noviembre un jour de novembre
voici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai donc cette vie particulière de de
nomades une une vie qui est finalement
plus très courante aujourd'hui en tout
cas dans le monde occidental
alors ce quotidien s'est un peu imposé à
moi avec avec ses concerts qui
s'enchaînent et quand j'étais enfant je
voyais mon grand père passionné de
petits avions qui partait au bout du
monde abordent ces petits coucous en
afrique souvent c'est vrai ça me faisait
rêver
et donc j'ai toujours été sensible aux
voyages et j'imaginais pas que que mes
notes de musique me mènerait à vivre
ainsi
et donc les concerts se sont enchaînés
et set j'ai adopté cette vie de deux
changements perpétuels et et surtout
cette vidéo ne donne rien à voir puisque
finalement quand on n'a pas de deux
maisons
on peut pas entreposer de choses et les
années passant je me suis rendu compte
le luxe que c'était de ne rien posséder
et aujourd'hui je protège beaucoup ce ce
quotidien et cette spécificité
je crois comme certains que les on
n'appartient plus aux choses que les
choses qui nous appartiennent et je fais
le plus tôt le l'apologie de des cadeaux
éphémère plutôt que des cadeaux
matériels parfois on a on peut penser
que lorsque avec 60 euros on s'achète
une chemise on à cette chemise pour un
plaisir plus long que si on invite un
ami a dîné au restaurant mais moi je
fais plutôt le choix de de ses plaisirs
plaisirs éphémères
j'aime l'idée d'un 1 d'un bon dîner avec
deux chers amis ou de gens que je ne
connais pas j'aime je privilégie plutôt
le lin les mômes en effet mère pleurer
devant un film ou être émerveillés
devant un paysage plutôt que d'essayer
de posséder les choses et je crois que
la quête de liberté dans laquelle je me
suis engagé en tout cas fait fait sens
pour moi et je vais pas développer plus
longtemps mais j'ai une autre chose une
question que je me pose qui est très
différente de tout ce que vous venez
d'entendre par rapport à la musique
classique je partage cette question j'ai
pas de réponse je joue une musique dite
classique qui est une une musique du
passé
en tout cas pour la grande majorité est
sauf que ces musiques classiques du
passé ont forcément été actuelle un
temps et aujourd'hui on a cette image de
la musique du classique comme une
musique savante intellectuelle du passé
qui s'adresse à un public savant
intellectuelle du passé
or moi je ne crois pas j'ai été
passionné par et je le reste
par cette étude infinie de ces grands
compositeurs de ces génies de la musique
beethoven bach mozart mais j'aime aussi
la musique d'aujourd'hui et j'aime
penser cette musique influencée du monde
aujourd'hui on a cette chance de pouvoir
voyager que les cultures se croisent et
je crois que les style musical musicaux
ma maman professeur de français n'aurait
pas apprécié ça je crois que les styles
musicaux peuvent être transversaux aussi
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être ce que je
pense
la nouvelle révolution musicale et donc
j'aime penser la musique classique comme
une aussi une musique d'aujourd'hui qui
est ouverte sur le monde l'est et les
styles et pour terminer cette heureuse
après midi je vais jouer l'un de ses
morceaux dans cet élan et dans cette
philosophie qui était composée par mon
cher papa qui m'a tendu cette fameuse
guitare quand j'étais tout petit mon
papa et philippe cau vent et ce morceau
a été écrit pour mon anniversaire pour
mes 12 ans ça s'appelle rock typique aux
vins merci
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]